[Musique]
des publicités sur la nostalgie qui est
important oui et qui qui nous rappelle
que la publicité c'est pas simplement ce
qu'ils jouent à la télévision la
publicité c'est aussi la trame musicale
tout ce qui contribue à créer la
personnalité depuis des décennies on
nous abreuve de slogan accrocheur sur
les lèvres
jamais sans mon lait franchement
meilleur ou encore deux c'est mieux
à la limite ch prétendrait que le lait
il est même au québec qui c'est assez
unique à l'échelle planétaire pour jeter
un coup d'oeil sur l'ensemble des
campagnes de mystère il est sophistiqué
sophistiqué oui mais est il aussi
essentiel qu'on veut nous le faire
croire
j'ai grandi en ayant l'impression que je
devais absolument voir du lait pour être
en bonne santé que le lait faisait
partie d'une alimentation équilibrée et
à se vêtir elysiques non c'est pas
nécessaire dans son essai vaches à lait
elise des zones y émettant doute
l'obligation d'avoir du lait dans notre
régime pour semer des produits laitiers
ça va pas nous tuer en support à ses
potes poison non plus mais c'est pas
nécessaire et après et des arguments
éthiques
et il ya des arguments environnementaux
qui vont dans ce sens qui voudraient
peut-être mieux réduire la consommation
voire ne pas en consommer du tout
l'internet fourmille de sites militants
qui font en ce moment le procès du lait
et de l'industrie laitière
mais je pense qu'il faut pour démoniser
un aliment comme le je pense que c'est
encore bon aliment mais michel lucas
chercheur émérite à l'université laval
et harvard minimise les bienfaits du
lait est-ce que ça a un effet sur la
structure osseuse est ce que c'est un
effet sur la fracture de la hanche qui
est un problème relié à l'ostéoporose et
les évidences les méta analyse
actuellement publiés montrent que
finalement le lait n'est pas cet effet
n'ont aucun effet protecteur contre les
fractures de la hanche
en voilà une bombe
pire encore les jeunes hommes grands
consommateurs de lait seraient eux plus
à risque
la consommation du lait n'est fait sur
la structure osseuse peut vous permettre
d'être peut-être plus grand mais dès le
plus grand sur un risque de fracture
les producteurs laitiers du canada
continue pourtant de véhicules et que la
consommation de lait prévient
l'ostéoporose
si on consomme pas de l'ain point de
produits l'été c'est difficile d'aller
chercher suffisamment de calcium et
vitamine d selon ce que les
recommandations sont est ce que vous
allez nécessairement faire de
l'ostéoporose
peut-être peut-être pas mais vous à vous
augmentez vos risques
la recommandation veut qu'on consomme de
deux à quatre portions de lait et de
produits laitiers par jour
dans les faits les deux tiers des gens
ne boivent pas de l'est c'est un souci
pour les producteurs laitiers les
québécois ne consomme pas encore
suffisamment de produits laitiers pour
la très grande majorité d'entre eux et
on a un effort à faire de ce côté le
camp professionnel de la santé
je suis préoccupé parce que quand je
vois des ados qui au lieu de boire du
lait à boire des boissons gazeuses ou
d'autres boissons sucrées saint briac
comme maman aussi ça me préoccupe
je trouve que nos efforts ils sont
investis de ce côté ne foutais disent
les végétaliens comme élise des zones y
est selon eux il est contre nature de
boire le lait d'une autre espèce puisque
les trois quarts de la planète ne le
font pas et ne s'en porte que mieux
pas très d'accord avec ce propos
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez des
populations comme les populations qui
vit aux vacances erding mais les gens
qui vivent en grèce a et kyriat ce sont
deux endroits où les gens vivent très
longtemps et en très très très bonne
santé et ce sont des bons consommateurs
de produits laitiers vont consommer
surtout d
des logos et des fromages moins de lait
mais ça fait partie d'une alimentation
de qualité
la notion que les populations qui
consomment pas de lait ou peu de lait
ont pas de ses opposants ont eu une très
bonne santé au sol c'est un mythe total
en asie en troll qui est souvent donné
en exemple
l'ostéoporose est un problème de santé
publique qui est un très haut dans la
liste
et ce quand ce polar les asiatiques mais
quand c'était libertaire par exemple
l'industrie laitière mène une bataille
de l'information dont le but de contrer
les attaques dont elle est la cible
par exemple sur les cancers les gras
saturés et le cholestérol il
consommateurs de lait et de produits
laitiers qui soit à faible teneur en
matières grasses ouvertement régulière
on semble
indiqué qu'au contraire ils ont un
risque plus faible de maladies
cardiovasculaires et surtout d'avc
certains cultivent malgré tout la
science du doute
on n'est plus dans les dents dans l'est
dans les années 50 où la seule source de
protéines ou la seule source de calcium
accessible c'étaient les produits
laitiers l'alimentation des canadiennes
et canadiens s'est diversifiée on n'a
plus besoin aujourd'hui de consommer
autant produits laitiers qu'on le conte
le faisait depuis on se doute bien que
toutes les industries alimentaires
jouent du coude pour maintenir leurs
parts de marché et espère garder leur
place dans le nouveau guide alimentaire
à paraître chez glénat et incontournable
imaginons soudainement qu'on dise ici
dès que tel produit n'a mérité de
figurer dans le guide vous pouvez
imaginer l'impact ça pourrait avoir par
la suite
rappelons que l'industrie laitière c'est
le tiers de l'agriculture québécoise
plus de 82000 emploi etc à l'échelle
canadienne
elle représente plus de 6 milliards de
dollars du produit intérieur brut
michel lucas a collaboré avec les
chercheurs de harvard qui propose une
nouvelle répartition des nutriments
cela donne une assiette santé limitant
la place du lait dans notre alimentation
à moins de deux portions la base
l'alimentation des omnivores des
végétaux ou donc les fruits les légumes
les noix les légumineuses des céréales
entières
si on va vers ça vous êtes gardien à
tout prix si vous ajoutez des produits
laitiers comme le yogourt des fromages
c'est encore mieux si vous ajoutez du
poisson c'est bien aussi
tout ça se construit comme ça
ni aliment miracle ni poison un verre de
lait c'est bien mais deux ce n'est pas
nécessairement mieux
[Musique]